[Music]
the rock does to care but I can't reach
them over radio their comms must be down
what's your status
already here Yuri I thought you said it
was secure it was let's go
maybe it's not as bad as it looks love
the optimism but in my experience when
it looks bad it's usually worse look out
[Music]
hold on
you okay yeah welcome to the park just
in time for the fireworks
looks like we made parole boys electro
why is he letting everyone out I'll head
for the main control center and see how
bad the situation got it I'll go join
the party
everyone just quietly go back into your
cells and lock the door behind you like
fish in a barrel that doesn't sound good
oh hi RINO hope you like surprise spider
surprise is he talking about hey watch
me just trapped in a prison with every
criminal I put away in the last eight
years no biggie
electro must be working for someone this
is too good to be true
scorpion can you hold on a minute I was
in the middle of a phone call and it was
business
[Music]
don't let up lost you please check it
there you okay not really
electro Rhino and now scorpion are all
on the loose what's going on in the rest
of the prison Cameron I'll give you a
sitrep soon okay I'll keep tracking
electro come on spider-man I thought
this was it shake gotta stop this guy
[Music]
if you tell me who you're working for
I'll go easy on you can't stock it but
I'm flattered that you still try nobody
ever takes me up on that offer
vulture long time no see we're gonna
have so much sorry no time to talk
okay I got the security cameras back
online how's it look
well it looks like the entire population
of the rabbit escape
that makes five of your worst enemies
that are now on the loose for a second
there I thought you were serious I am
serious I have to go some of them are
heading into the city this is not
yeah
keep chasing parties almost dark
[Music]
a lot wrong stop
how do you like my new suit dashing
where'd you get it it's an exclusive
club
[Music]
remember he said not to kill him good
idea in fact we don't have to do this at
all if you don't want to
we definitely want
[Music]
you today